was Chancellor Angela Merkel's first
parliamentary speech since announcing
she would step down as party leader and
she was unusually passionate she
vigorously defended the you and
migration pact saying acting
internationally was the only way to
solve global problems it's in our
national interest to improve the
conditions for both refugees on the one
hand and employment migration on the
other this was a budget debate
traditionally a chance for the
opposition to attack the government's
policies but the largest opposition
party the far-right AFD is under
pressure itself stung by a scandal over
campaign donations the AF DS
parliamentary co-leader lashed out you
have no right to criticize us on moral
grounds step out of your Glass House and
stop throwing stones you'll only hit
yourself in the end Stefan
Merkel was unfazed the nice thing about
free debates is that everyone can talk
about whatever they think is important
for the country smaller opposition
parties took the government to task for
quarreling and inaction people are sick
of the coalition with it's bad
compromises and impasses it's clearly
incapable of solving people's real
problems this coalition is like a
self-help group it's concerned only with
itself and not with the needs of society
after such unusually animated
parliamentary exchanges politicians
returned to the rather drier task of
discussing next year's budget
you